what's this little thirst trap what do
you want to adopt ELLs next high school
movie will close it out with our
relationship advice sup tits McGee
what's up Brandon I wanted to get a
little relationship advice from you guys
so this past quarantine I've just been
staying at my girlfriend's house and her
grandma lives with her and her grandma
will not stop hitting on me like she's
clearly trying to make some moves and I
was just wondering like I don't want to
be disrespectful there she's very old
and like my girlfriend loves her
obviously so how do I like you know tell
her what's up without you know
disrespecting her and my girlfriend
that's all I was wondering hope you guys
can help out Gang Gang buzzbuzz getting
old ladies need that's what's going on
here dude she's thirsty for this young
21 Jump Street fella you feel me yeah
get her some petagrams dude get us some
graham crackers them old ladies like
graham crackers got to keep her pipe
down keep her busy dude keep her busy
your crossword puzzles dude yeah I think
that's good it's the core Jerry
Springer's old Jerry Springer's [ __ ]
love that the mold [ __ ] love that
damn finger what's up dude
grandma ain't gonna be worried about
your [ __ ] should be worried about Jerry
Springer I don't mean I think I don't
know she's worried about his [ __ ]
Brendan I think she's just hitting on
him a lot you know it sounds like it
sounds like grandma's lonely thanks
maybe just hang out maybe sign her up on
rickles calm or the [ __ ] they have for
old people dating apps like my hair's
getting messed up oh he's messed up
you're fine okay I want to know I want
to let this young man know first of all
dude what cheap young man is shacking up
with his girlfriend and her grandmother
during quarantine or any teen okay I
don't think he's ever a good time to go
live with your girlfriend in our
grandmother yeah especially if the
grandmother unless the grandma's cooking
doing laundry and stuff and you're
eating at three o'clock it's your last
meal of the day she goes about around
4:00 do ya being caged in I think you
got to get a job man you got to get out
and about I think you need to
stablished a little bit dude if you
don't have a place and your girls stay
in there man and the role is that you're
over at your girl's place then you get
what you get bro yeah I'm saying give em
a little sneak peek it's last thing you
do from [ __ ] feeding off all their
groceries and [ __ ] yeah deuce your rent
son flirt with the grandma do anything
yeah we tease yeah tickle that old back
strap bra you know what I'm the same
give her a back rub your [ __ ]
pedophile yeah dude quit milling around
the house leeching off of a woman and
her ill grandmother semi ill sexually
motivated that lonely ground give her a
back rub tossing that [ __ ] hot tub
dude she'd have a great time yeah you
know he's not in your situation young
men who have their own apartment yeah
young me love their [ __ ] two-handed yeah
get your [ __ ] in two hands and then go
like this done it son yeah I think you
got a frickin take some ownership mane
you get what you would you allow
yourself to give yeah dude buy a box out
of Golden Girls and tell her shut the
[ __ ] up I wouldn't do that I would get
the set and say thank you guys for
letting me live here or that you know
I'm trying to say yeah I'll tell you
what better be doing these little
[ __ ] wearing a mask the mold people
dying left and right anyone should be
worried about coab it's probably this
grandma that's why she's hitting on you
that's a good point maybe this fine
heavens doorstep ready to get the [ __ ]
out of this world dude yeah and you're
out here little thirst-trapping--
meeting back not wearing a mask yes you
probably trying to get you to pop hop
into that slick - one more time before
she leave the earth so I think you got
it look man do work or get out man yeah
whining us ain't gonna help it yeah
don't hate the wrinkles bro we got
enough of our own problems we're trying
to kill each other in a car accident
yeah and then we're trying to see if one
of us to go to prison for life and you
got problems is grounding sweet open her
arms
god damn do you get your life together
yeah dude it is together it looks like
he stole the granddad's clothes like the
way he dresses looks like an old man
maybe it's the granny being like ah this
is this is this is Jerry my husband she
might just be lonely as [ __ ] man
what do now in you guys's cultures what
kind of stuff we do what do
grandmother's do there though you feel
like a stronger position than they do
here in a mystical more care of them
right oh yeah Asians are very
family-oriented and you also your
grandma's lived at 200 so then yeah
absolutely they're gonna be around
forever so you better get used to it
yeah you gotta get used to it
chin you take care of grandmas and [ __ ]
still yeah our grandma used to live with
us and then she was just like I said
she's a smoker drinker smoke every day
like constantly amen
she didn't die from that she got hit by
a car she was like very very late her
who was driving the car and who was in
the passenger seat we went to jail yeah
was she drinking and did you agree to
get in the car and then she wrecked no
but by the way the person that drove was
Mexican Wow
was it uber no they know what they're
super back then what was a taxi no it's
just a car no cars there's a person Oh
shoes crossing the street in New Mexico
she would buy a bus stop this once a
Canadian or Mexican and that's how she
passed away that's not about oh my
that's so iris iris car bomb yeah also
known as frog how old was she I think
she was in like late 70s early early
eighties and that's young for Asians
just getting started it's late high
school yeah like half of her life
constantly never didn't have a smoke I
never down just spitballing ideas here
we're in the circle of trust which she
changed smoked and played the slots I
don't think we ever took her to a casino
oh wow that's but if you did you
probably 100% you don't change smoke and
not play the salon she barely lived I
know well she lived a crazy life but how
crazy drinking is smoking all the time
sounds like she lived and she was strong
too was she very strong she says what
she bench I don't think she's ever been
just kept picking up stuff all the time
Karen stuff around the house moving our
bikes how strong very strong how strong
I would say if I was her age I wouldn't
be as strong as her you weren't strong
meet me at 240 Sun differences grandma
how strong then there's weight room
strong I'd like to see your grandma best
leave
team what's up mark what about
grandparents in Ireland what is that
like stick around the house doesn't know
I've never seen them in an old folks
home Renton they don't do that stand the
farm but then don't drive in there like
84 driving yeah crashing into people but
they're not going fast enough you know
yeah driving tractors out milking cows
there's a lot of respect with old people
there yeah big time
oh yeah cuz they've good stories so
you're like your teeth will pop out and
it was like okay you're some knowledge
man grandma grandpa still life mm-hmm I
got one grandma alive that's it oh yeah
what does she like she's about 300
pounds uh I used to hide Snickers under
her bed
oh yeah yeah she swims every day even
now she's like 98 or 99
300 pounds since I've known her she swim
every single day what does she bench
about to swim in the pool yeah you know
in the one-piece at the YMCA that
vegetable oh yeah just swimming in
George she's nothing that one piece son
bro why don't we call water jorts I'm
all about George in general you know I
really am too man I think everything's
headed that direction because yeah well
it's just like more comfort it's like
people are wearing comfortable stuff
everywhere now you know like it used to
be people in business suits and stuff
and now people especially coming out of
quarantine what's it gonna be like
everyone's in sweats these days people
you're wearing a hammock does this look
like your [ __ ] bedroom put some
clothes on any wind sweats all the time
the airport man yeah a little pride you
know baby South Kingstown George you
know the ball to V charts and scarves
not knows who the two of you you can see
that George P working with the jorts man
you're not taking out the front
sometimes mmm
yeah that pressure yep you know I've
always got to get out
[Music]
the King nothing
[Music]